do I have anything to apologize to you
for um I think you actually do this time
what do I have to no I I'm not looking
for an apology no let me I understand
that you're going through some let me
know what happened you were just really
like encourageable and and like rude
when the last couple times you you were
here you're right I was and I do want to
apologize for that I was going through a
very rough time and I feel like I was
being a bit debasing if that makes sense
yes that's a good word for off-kilter
I feel like I was being an obnoxious
vain piece of
[__] I don't want you to feel like I
take you for Grounded Mark no it's okay
I understand you're going through some
you know it's very scary what you're
going through with the deportation and
the suicides and all that all that stuff
yeah mostly the suicides I suppose is
what uh the deportation right should be
scary it's more the sense of
uh feeling like completely out of place
with the world world I guess but I'm
sorry you're right what a monster I've
been we still love
you and I still love you more in all
honesty with all the being and fiber
that exists within me I love your hair I
don't love it I adore it I feel like it
is adorable if Sharon Stone had teddy
bear herself it's like Sharon
Stone the Sharon Stone impersonator from
Reno so you're you're almost I mean
because sometimes you with your crazy
wigs your your hair is thick and full
and beautiful if you let it grow out
you'd be a You' have W hair that most
women would die for right
Adonis but you put these crazy wigs on
and you look like a sociopath sociopath
sociopath and look at this this is
beautiful this is beautiful yeah this is
beautiful your words and I think you're
starting to look more feminine thank you
I'm starting to feel a lot more feminine
if your eyebrows were not so thick thick
sorry I just I look at car deline and I
look at Kendall Jenner and I think why
not but you're right if I tweeze my
eyebrows did my face girls boys can wear
jeans cut their hair short but you'd
love to know wouldn't you what it feels
like for a girl you're a beautiful
creature regardless of what you are
beautiful creatures 2013 I Christ in
2024 the year of the girl girl right
girl girl power if anyone out there for
your consideration Rebecca Olson wants
to be a girl can I be a girl again
please please 17 Again can I just like
do like a Parent Trap body switch or
whatever Freaky Friday scenario just be
a girl again I never got to be a girl
I'm not a girl not yet a woman you're
still young yet you know what people
keep saying when they see me now they're
like we're we were rooting for you every
seen that tire Banks clip where she
where they're like we were rooting for
you we were all rooting for you it's all
I see we're rooting for
you people who see you on the street and
recognize you oh my God it's yesterday
these Latina girls like literally came
up to me and they were like I I don't
want to say like twerking on the car but
but at this point it was like they're
like Rebecca yo Rebecca and they were
hand money and like oh my God is and um
you're becoming a star I'm becoming a
star I'm becoming the portrait of a lady
or is it dor and gray do I mean do you
feel how much love you get out there I
love so much more I can't believe I
anyone would ever love me I I cannot
imagine that this creature would ever
deserve love you do you totally do you
do I don't believe that
no you are you are incredibly lovable I
feel like I'm na
naive and exceptionally broadly boyish
but the boyish look is in with Mumu now
I suppose a British
boyishness I don't know if I love or
hate it it feels like a boy's view of
what an older girl would look like right
isn't that me kind of a boy's view of
what an older woman would look like
isn't that the preconceived notion of
how I devot my time your cardigan
sweater is
not something a young lady would be
wearing probably an older woman oh well
you know I was reading uh Vogue recently
not this copy but the Kate Winslet
[__] cover two British women on the
cover of Vogue is that in a row or I
can't remember but anyway I guess the
British are taking over again um but it
said that uh apparently um it they were
talking about a Alaya Ain alayia was a
very prolific designer in the 80s and
90s remember he did Grace Jones and
incredible leather work um I prefer CL
Mona and the the chief designer Peter mu
who used to work under ra Simmons was
like um the mother was
wearing Alaya the daughter
wasn't but ala was very much made for a
younger audience at the
time it's an A
liia but I'm a liar because I just want
to be a little girl I want to I want to
get myself back like I want to punch
myself in the face sometimes you know
what I mean I'm like [__] this idiot
[__] this dumb little boy he's [__]
up my life he's destroying any chances
of me ever becoming like I'll never be
Shin
Sheena if you hear this I'll Never Be
The Goddess that you are I'll never be a
real one like you
Sheena
sincerely
Rebeca but it's a new year new me what
happened to your forehead
violence a little bit of ultra violence
what happened some guy bashed me with
what oh no he bashed my head against a
Subway
grade this happened years ago in New
York really yes oh in New York yes in
New York when I lived in New York you
still have the scar I still have the
scar I can't afford the surgery it's
like I still have the scar in my leg
from my well that was from the auto
accident yes from the auto
accident o it's a bad one could you
imagine blocking an entire
planet with two well one was an act of
Shame the other was an act of mou
but which was which shane Car Mulligan
great movie by the way great [__]
movie well not not Maestro I mean shame
I haven't seen Maestro I don't know
Leonard Bernstein was it a
composer we are in LA right this is the
real La Maestro
beef have you seen that new show beef on
Netflix I have not it's incredible I
think it like it [__] round the gamut
at the emmies did you see the emmies I
did not they tried to do like a tribute
to television Anthony Anderson hosted I
um I was a little
surprised but good for Natasha Leon and
Tracy Alis Ross for honing it in right
at the end just in
case I Love Lucy I feel
ill I love you I love you despite all
your crazy personalities I still love
you how many personalities do I have I I
was trying to count this morning there's
there's probably about 10 can you name
them or are they well I mean I mean like
so there's there's this belligerent out
of control
crazy rockar just just you know that
that that was you know one of them I
mean when you had the crazy wigs on and
you're just screaming and like oh my
feet are hurting and get me a [__]
room and all this you know that Rebecca
then there's the the really kind of
quiet and demure one usually you're like
coming down from something I think mhm
kind of like I suppose I am right now
you can barely speak in fact when that
when that's going on the the one of the
perhaps my favorite Rebecca is the one
where you're pretty much like you are
now where you're cogent and sharp witted
and considerate and kind and you know I
feel blonde right now I feel like a but
then but then my other favorite Rebecca
is the one where I picked you up and you
had your head almost shaved mhm and
you're just transgressive sharp as a t
nose I was thinking of shaving my head
yeah where you threw the water bottle
out of the car I love that [__] scene
that's my favorite that's my favorite
Rea
moment that's my favorite Rebecca moment
I honestly feel like I don't want to say
there's a term that I hated we were
talking about England earlier right and
you said that you were going to London
tomorrow there's a term I hate that they
use in London where they say you're
monging out right when you get high they
say you're monging out and I hated that
terminology but honestly I feel like
that's kind of how I'm behaving is and
how I'm presenting to society uh an
Envision of this idiot angry man
kind of like God almost you know what I
mean this little Lord
fonty
likeone I'm not a real woman you know
what I mean who is that idiot somebody
stab him in the [__] face
immediately it's like uh there are
problems in the world there are bigger
problems than uh someone's inability to
procure a sex change Jud
to I used to look on the internet and
and and search my name in a Google
Search and I would find so much
information that was just was horrifying
you'd see my address you'd see phone
numbers you'd see my relatives you'd see
all my health information all kinds of
stuff it's like I don't want that
information out there data Brokers sell
your information to scammers spammers
and anyone else who may want to Target
you and that's why I signed up for Aura
the sponsor of today's video Aura shows
you which data Brokers are selling your
information and automatically submits
opt out requests for you cleaning up my
information
not only reduces the amount of spam I
get but it protects me from hackers who
could use this information to help them
access my social media accounts bank
accounts and other sensitive
information it's really easy to set up
so I don't have to download several
different apps to get things like
antivirus VPN password management
parental controls identity theft
Insurance and more I get everything at
one affordable price you may already
have one or two of these tools already
but not having auras like locking your
front door and leaving your back door
wide open I'm I'm too busy to deal with
this stuff and that's why I appreciate
that aura is always on keeping me safe
so I don't have to worry about this kind
of stuff I value my privacy and if you
value yours you can go to aura.com
softwhite underbelly to start your twoe
free trial the link is in the video
description box below now back to the
video
thanks oh I was supposed to go to the
[__] oh my God I forgot to go to the
transl Coalition yesterday they said
they were giving out clothes and food go
to the what oh they invited me the
transa Coalition was standing outside
the um train station Union Station
giving out flyers and they they gave me
a flyer to go and I forgot to go I just
remembered shout out to the trans Latina
women's Coalition for being the
only public trans Authority in all of
Los Angeles thank you for someone who
for any organization honestly who would
um protect trans
youth you know forever protect trans
Youth and I pity the fool
but I I want a message out there to the
kids you know what I mean if anyone out
there is thinking of transitioning I
want you to feel your body because it's
a physical decision right I personally
am having problems right now because of
the legal nature of my life my body is
under attack right now or let's say
policing in the wake of me too and all
that I don't want to be the woman at the
back of the barns a
noble you will only
truly
feel on a physical level because it's a
physical transition let me say that if
you're ever confused it's a physical
thing like if um Uncle Sam would permit
me the [__] and the
moans I would be forever your mistress
America but yeah no literally CU it's a
physical thing it's a bodily thing there
is a spirit right but if you want to do
drag you want to experiment because I
was speaking to a friend about this
earlier anyone who's ever confused I
would suggest
immediately identifying your body I
don't I don't know what to say
that all right question time sorry I was
I was just about to ask you I was just
trying to do anything for Trans youth do
I count as trans
youth I just phased out of Youth you
it's interesting you know your videos
are so popular probably the whole world
has watched them at some point you think
I would think your family knows that
you're what's going on but they haven't
reached out to you I doubt they have
have they reached out to you no but they
could easily oh and they haven't oh I
was just questioning I don't know
honestly a lot of the families of people
I've intervie interviewed have have
reached out to me after I but mine
haven't well then I guess they have no
clue what's going on because they would
have reached out to you and probably um
ceas him desisted or anything like that
how could they not know what's going on
honestly I have no
clue I just find it interesting that no
one has ever said hey what's going on
with her son
or daughter what is going on with her
son or daughter well I doubt anyone
would want to say her daughter also um I
have no clue um to my family if you ever
see this I love you and I'm sorry and
I'm sorry that I want to be a woman I'm
sorry that I came to America to be a
woman to my father I'm sorry that I
abandon you if you have your number I
love you I love you Dad to my mom I love
you too but to my dad I'm super
sorry if my dad is out there hearing
this I'm sorry if you feel like I left
you behind I'm sorry if you feel like
you brought me to America and that I
just ditched you here that you ditched
me here no hard feelings I love you you
thank you so much and to my mother you
are a beautiful kind woman you are a
beautiful soul who does not understand
the limitations of her own ineducation
the limitations of her own lack of
awareness when it comes to not just
herself but the world around her and I'm
sorry if I ever made you
feel
incapacitated or incapable in any way
because you are an incredible woman you
are one of the most beautiful women in
the world to me if not the most
beautiful woman in the world you will
always be my mother and to me you are
the most sacred thing ever you deserve
to be worshiped as an
icon of not just suffrage but of quiet
underestimation you're so beautiful mom
I [__] love you and the way the world
looks down upon you I can only imagine
to be belittled that way as a woman
coming from woman to woman or man to
woman or whatever to be looked down upon
especially cuz your kid did some [__]
made some mistake your kid wanted to
chop his dick off so I hope honestly
that at least they're unaware of this
because I would worry not for their
safety but for the safety of not just
the reputations but their
psychology I would worry for their
inability to conduct their lives simply
because they would feel like failures
like I said when my mom found out I was
gay this is before I realized I knew
what a transwoman was that alone that I
could transition into a
woman she started hurting herself she
started like slapping herself
catatonically I would would never hurt
her and I would never feel hurt by any
of the abuse that she may or may not
whatever that doesn't matter to me
that's all water under a
bridge
however I want you to know from a woman
to a woman you are every part the
class class class act that I possibly
may never be and you'll always be the
real thing mom I [__] love you more
than anything
you're a beautiful woman and I apologize
for
everything whether or not I've made
mistakes I don't know I know if it's
wrong for me to feel this way to anyone
out there who's had this experience I
don't know like is it bad to want
to mutilate your body just because you
feel a certain way I don't know it's
just a penis at the end of the day like
dude you're a woman but you're such an
innocent beautiful girl and there's I
just remember watching movies and [__]
you know what I mean with you and
honestly I'm
I love you Mom that's all I can say I
love you
mom from a daughter to a mother from a
son to a mother from a apparently a
cardigan a shift skirt and a pair of Dr
Martin brogues to a woman Mom I love you
thank you thank you for being my mother
mother mother mother witch witch witch
www.m
mother.com
notor not net and
yet the implication of
either mother.com doet or.org pick
one. a okay USA first of all USA
honestly I feel like I should buy
tickets to the Super Bowl at this point
so this is this is clean for you is this
clean for you I mean you you seem like
you're clean right now let's say I
am I gave you money last night I don't
know if you got V with that
but a ppack pack of
smokes Ms beauty is a gesture I
appreciate the
gesture but you know so I'm back to the
drug
use is this without using for how
long let's say a week really mhm oh no
way longer I think it's been about two
three weeks give take how why is
this because of you mark because you've
been such a positive influence on my
life Prada Eternal jewelry fine gold
this is why
beautiful which you prefer the first or
the second see I prefer the second I
can't see it is that Maya Hawk feel like
it looks like Maya Hawk you know Ethan
Hawk and um Thurman's daughter looks
like see Jimmy Mendoza my friend
yesterday was showing me this old clip
of um Thurman doing the birth of Venus
remind me Madonna in four rooms you ever
seen four
rooms never with uh Tim uh
not Tim Curry what's his name Tim Roth
not Tim Roth you were thinking about
funny games earlier anyway so um yeah
her they con her Affy and she's
basically Dr in PVC this is around this
was a year after the human nature video
came out see this Rebecca the Rebecca
that's that I'm talking to right now you
could do anything in your life you could
be a huge star you could take all the
notoriety you've gotten from these
YouTube videos on my channel and you
could do you can create a YouTube
channel of your own and you could
be could you help me with that I'll help
you with it could you help me a studio
you can shoot it here I I'll give you a
room to shoot here will you will you
give me a room and board we can work
that out work it
out I'd love to work out but if you
could stay in this state of mind cuz I
think I think this is a very popular
Rebecca for my audience and Z you know
what I hate about Vogue an [__] leave
events no offense to an leitz I'm sure
you're a very wonderful woman but [__]
you an Lovitz please I need I need a
real Vogue I need a vog it's not Vogue
France it's vog I need a num I need a
stepen Klein Vogue USA cover before I
die please it's my dying wish I mean he
just shot the VY Fair um Hollywood
portfolio and Julia Garner was in it
remember she played um an Deli you heard
of anadelia have you no you don't know
who anadelia
is refresh my memory anadel Anna
soken I call her an delvo honestly cuz
she looks She's So Parisian to me I mean
it sounds really basic to say [__]
[__] someone stop the smile in the
face um remember the um the scammer she
tried to screw a City National Bank out
of $100 million to start the anadelia
foundation the anadelia foundation what
did I do with my life I failed to chop a
dick off she's still in America she's
wearing an ankle monitor and they held a
fashion show on the roof of her rothco's
rooms anyway on the roof of her
building and I think she looked
incredible I was so surprised she lost
so much weight in
jail
show so much
weight like it really did the whole VR
Wang thing you know VR Wang used to work
at the YSL
store in New York I think so was either
New York or
Paris I wish I could refresh my memory
can't believe they're still talking
about sopia Copa bi
collaboration do you like Margaret qu I
don't know who she is she's um what's
her name's daughter
mcdow's daughter what's that Andy
mcdow's daughter she was in the kenzel
world she she did a show on Netflix
called
maid dor Margaret kie she married Jack
anov
anyway do you know Andy McDow I don't
see you you you and I run in different
circles Groundhog Day I don't run in any
circles beautiful bag it's a backpack
look how put together you are today too
this is the most i' the most put
together I've ever seen you you dressed
beautifully I really wasn't trying I was
going for so let's go talk about your
transition again yes like you keep
talking about chopping something off but
let's say you did what what the majority
of trans women do which is to start
taking hormones which is impossible for
me because I don't even have health
insurance so I can literally go to an ER
tell them I want to kill myself but I
can't get access to hormones without the
proper identification or I don't know
what it
is so I want to go back down to the
trans Latino's col because I went to the
LGBT Center in La I mean sorry in well I
don't want to say West Hollywood I want
to say more Hollywood on mcaden and they
wouldn't help me but this is La if you
can get fentanyl and crack cocaine then
you should be able to get hormones
exactly it doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense it literally makes no sense
the prevalence of crack cocaine and
Tents and [__] garbage on the streets
versus the ability for one
individual to enage themselves right
right in suffragette martyrdom to the
body of a woman I would literally
transition to being a woman and I would
take
literally the period pain of every
woman for the right to be a woman
literally like combine all the periods
in the world right I take all that pain
and I want to be a woman that's a lot of
misery do you have do you have a knife
do you have the butcher knife we're
watching Rosemary's Baby earlier we
didn't even make it all the way to the
endless time because honestly um
I don't know who felt like it felt more
like a tele playay see Mr Mendoza was
saying earlier he preferred the uh NBC
remake with kahal buou a bouet of
flowers was salono who was an avatar did
an NBC T movie of Rosemary's Baby how
sincerely Rebeca Olson please I'm really
I'm asking I'm asking for a friend here
it's like Amy Schumer's leather special
I don't know it's like Amy Schumer and I
feel pretty versus Amy Schumer and train
rck so I'm sorry to interrupt but the
banter that you're talking right now if
you did that on your own and posted
videos on YouTube you would have a
following like that okay a big following
okay cool let's do it but you got to
stay away from all the [__] crazy
drugs um CU they take you down look
honestly Mark what I really want is to
audition for like a be movie or a
[__] independent film could you
arrange something like that do you think
do you have connections in that World
Mark well if you can consistently stay
in this Frame of Mind deal I bet you
things like that will open up for you
but it's your inconsistency that's the
problem do not mistake my
consistency for my transparency
sincerely Tiffany New York par no but
you're you're terribly inconsistent I
terribly inconsistent it is a fault of
mine I believe in Beauty he believes in
a beauty he's Venus as a girl you're
covering your face with your
hand I hate my
face I want to get it see you tonight
it's a bad idea right see you tonight
[__] it it's fine whatever whatever dude
this this guy wants to be a chick fine
whatever dude just let him be a chick
whatever so long as he's not ruining my
town except during the power Cuts
everyone hunkered down in Grim
sufferance sincerely skid apparently
this is report from Ukraine we're
currently on the brink of World War III
so I feel like there are priorities in
life I understand this but I want to be
a woman godamn it
but there are priorities we're on the
verge of a World
War oh syy Crawford for MCM oh we're
going to be all right but here so hear
me out hear me out Max Mar by I'll help
you start your little YouTube thing I'll
help you with the the payment because
you probably won't be able to receive
payments because you don't have a bank
account you don't have the ID all that
stuff but I can help you with that and
then the money that you generate which
will be significant I I can go to my
transition you can do it yourself and
that'll Fe so much better than if
somebody just paid for it like me
exactly well i' love I cannot pull out
money out of my pocket to pay for you
chopping off anything I just can't it's
just something against your beliefs I
understand yeah but but but I support
what you want thank you and and I
support that for myself as well thank
you honestly all I need I believe if you
stayed in this Frame of Mind Is there a
community out there of um trans women
who have any advice for a little trans
boy girl a little [__] uh girl not
from the Brewster project but from the
uh Cleo projects if you will the uh Adis
Ababa projects if you will anyone out
there with a piece of advice cuz the
only Queen I've met out there honestly
who I loved was Jasmine Masters and the
only words that came out of her lips
were hey [__] Shangela seemed a little
taken a back when advice in terms of
what in terms of anything dude Life
Style career dignity you don't need
advice any that thing hey Queens girls
where do we draw the line on
Dignity where when are you just a man in
a wig and when do you truly feel like a
woman I'm asking Gia I'm asking Sasha
I'm asking Nick Nikki tutorials hey
girls where's the dignity hey women
aren't our eyes up here but is our
dignity really down there oh no it's all
about my manhood isn't it well you know
what Little
Dicky that Devil's going to get you one
day max Mar styled by Karen roitfeld in
a Vogue creative director by Anna
Wintour see Karen always finds a way I
wanted Harper Bazar I got Vogue they
didn't have Harpers Bazaar at CVS do you
think they have a Harper Bazar here
somewhere here is I know that there's a
news sand there's one last news sand on
Mose not many anymore there's one left
and it sells every fashion magazine
right out in the open it's the last one
I just want go see our fashion book
before I die that's all I want the new
crr fashion book well I mean doing what
you're doing now staying in this Frame
of Mind Italian vog staying away from
the the meth I think could lead to
something like that I want to get it's
like what did doat say she quit the
nicotine I guess um I mean I quit meth
for Molly any
day you pre you prefer Molly I prefer
Molly I prefer
MDMA I prefer mdna normally when you
come in and you're high as a [__]
kite you're on Molly and I'm on meth I'm
not on Molly if I were on Molly I'd be
rolling I'd be rolling with the homies
I'd be with the young people instead of
sitting here like some old [__] hag
has been shriveled up do you see how do
you see how pathetic that life on skid
is though oh it is it's [__] pathetic
as [__] pathetic as [__] pathetic as
[__] guys remember this show so I was
monging on skid Road chel came and did a
show in Hollywood baby
so which do you think is the Mary Kate
and which do you think is the Ashley I'm
asking you viewers which do you think
cuz we got Paris we got Nikki right and
we got um Nicole Kidman I don't know
Anna eers who is
Dutch when you put Dutch d l a lad
anyway all it's missing is the te cuz I
am tea Hunty what is the t- sis is my
question so with your permission America
vote Rebecca Olson
girl maybe I can do standup comedy at
this point that's all I feel you can
totally do stand up comedy that's all
I'm [__] qualified to do at this
point like literally I don't feel like
any respectable job would accept any any
office just bypass all the respectable
jobs the small jobs and just I did with
all of no but with all you're already a
star well then where's the
uh tury the
consistency the consistency that's it
beyond the transp I'll help you in 17
different ways to get what you need of
the dolls but you need to be consistent
you can't show up next time I see you
and you're [__] high as a kite which
is what you typically
do the drugs are the key I know you I
know you love your drugs but [__] being
polite I'm going but I love that you
stayed away for a week that's great cuz
this Rebecca is the Rebecca that
everybody loves 3 weeks three weeks over
3 weeks
allegedly
allegedly I'm not rep see you know that
you know people talk about you know you
need to go to a rehab but I don't see
Rebecca ever going to a rehab [__] rehab
you would do it by yourself uh I would
if I wanted to right if you wanted to
you would do it by yourself I've been to
rehab it's not for for me people smoke
weed don't they people smoke weed isn't
that what they they call them reer
smokers or whatever the devil's rock
music and what I don't do Coke I wish I
did Coke I feel like you guys think I'm
some kind of like a crockor or whatever
but honestly I'm just someone who wants
to enjoy their life and I happen to find
a pure American Vice that broke bad and
even and is cheap and insensible and
makes me feel wild just makes me feel
like a complete animal you know when
they say life of the party or party
monster whatever I don't know
who was it who uh very notably was it
Aaron Carter or was it James Franco or
was it Courtney seml who died of a
methamphetamine was it Tia Tequila who
died of a meth
overdose I remember reading that not
just Heather ler but also Tera Reed did
meth
ironically weird stuff coming out of the
woodwork about um kind of former
a-listers you know what I mean who kind
of transition out like the Charlie Sheen
set you know what I mean remember um
Richie Sambora and all those kids Denise
Richards I wonder if Denise Richards has
ever done math Wild Things remember that
movie Wild Things what happened to Wild
Things what happened to sex porn love
dignity fame um America I love Abid
Elementary don't get me wrong I love
Quint Brunson I'm sure Quint Brunson is
a very wonderful woman but what happened
to America baby USA America baby freedom
of speech like USA like not just Ghost
World but like we were talking about the
hills earlier like The Hills Have Eyes
The Hills Have Eyes The Hills Have Eyes
too we're on the verge of the hills of
eyes three [__] nuclear meltdown
would you rather walk with the dead or
live with the Jet Set it's an honest
question America who would you rather
zombie or zombie boy zombie
orzo what's up to you
America I mean nothing against um
Celebrity Apprentice you know what but
you sat and worked your ass off for him
while he sat there looking like Casper
the ghost where you go Casper H H now as
for Star
Jones nothing to say about Star Jones
then where is Barbara Walters rest in
peace Barbara Walters rest in peace
Barbara Walters rest in
peace you ever seen the movie gotho with
Hollyberry and pel Cruz never saw it I
think JLA would have been great in that
movie you like being a blonde I love
being a blonde blonde ambition that's my
name November 5th this is brand new for
you no I'm sorry oh this is me me now
collection created by Jennifer Lopez in
me the art of Italian lre this is me dot
dot dot now that's what this feels like
this is me now Elaine
Bennis that's my current [__] modus
operandi Elaine [__]
Bennis I'm the Elaine Bennis of the
Upper East
Side I'm the ELA Bennis of society I got
a benis right here for you this V votes
America America first baby America wins
America oh I long to be an
American you want to be
Americano
Americo Americo okay Rebecca wonderful
seeing you again this is this is the
this is the best Rebecca you've but show
a long long
time is that it is it is I don't agree
with you I feel like that was I bet in
the comments
this is the see let see let's see in the
comments let's see in the comments how
in the comments do you read the comments
sometimes when you're not with
me an beautiful what do you think of vti
she just talk [__] about Kendall Jenner
almost could have cost for her career
but she's no Lexi bowling shout out Lexi
bowling and Vito chetti for [__] with
Kenji hey
Kendall you got a
light got a
light uh but I should be wearing black
I'm wearing white what a disaster he's
clean too Someday My Prince Will Come I
swear I swear he's a real man I swear he
loves me I swear he's Rich As [__] I
swear I swear I swear he's real I swear
he's a real man I marry myself or I
marry well of course Chanel 2012 2013
which the two lesbian brides and the
little boy come out so Mary K Ashley
remember that kid you were trying to
adopt oh yeah shout out to Otter Olsen
utto
Eisner I don't remember when your
birthday is but I love you utto
sincerely
motto motto is love you utto forever I
offer myself for aotto I love you utto
happy Birthday forever utto happy
birthday happy un birthday happy
birthday everyday Alto love you utto
love you Alto asnar Olen you give us all
hope you give us all hope you utto give
us all hope shout out Otto shout out
Phoenix shout
out
America if you're still there I love you
except me love me or don't I'm elen
benis signing out thank you re thank you
Mark you're amazing you're
amazing